into this what is functional programming
so there's not gonna be a lot of code
that I'm going to show it's mostly going
to be talking about concepts and
functional programming there'll be a
little bit of code and talking about
what people mean by functional
programming and how we might want to
broaden what people mean by functional
programming to talk about some other
stuff in this Meetup so first of all if
you're going to talk about functional
programming it's good to talk about what
a function is right so at its base a
function is a map between inputs and
outputs specifically it's a map so that
for any set of inputs you get one output
of course you can define you can define
this in a lot of different ways you
could sometimes you'll see a table like
right here you'll have a table where you
have inputs on the left and outputs on
the right or you'll see it in like a
more mathematical setting where you have
like f of X and then some transformation
on X and then you know this this
mathematical definition of a function is
a little bit different than the way we
use the word function in programming
which generally means procedure we mean
some place where we're going to run a
piece of computation and then bring the
results back to the main loop or the
main part of the program
so when functional programmers say
functional programming they mean viewing
your computation through this lens
through this idea of inputs and outputs
and the closer you can get to that the
more like functional programming the
more sorry the more functional
programming you're doing yeah so like I
said what does functional programming a
common answer the basic unit of
computation is a function so that being
said when you actually do functional
programming a lot of times it doesn't
really look like what you're doing is
writing down functions and then
computing inputs and outputs
instead things look pretty crazy and
this is a sample of reason I could have
just as easily put a sample of Haskell
or Scala or really any functional
programming language I've ever used
while it's well I can understand how I'm
using functions it oftentimes doesn't
feel like that's what I'm doing so I
wanted to talk a little bit you know
about what is it that we're getting if
it's not just about inputs and outputs
what is it that we're getting out of
functional programming but first I was
really curious just how many of you have
actually written programs in a
functional setting before I guess raise
your hand if you've written functional
programs before okay pretty good
probably about half the group so that's
that's awesome and I guess raise your
hand if you'd like to do it again
I guess judging from you know being here
that's really great you know a lot a lot
of people haven't a lot of people don't
really know what it is that functional
programmers are talking about if they've
ever heard of it at all so I'm gonna try
and go through some of what it is
so before I was talking about you know
what a definition of functional
programming is and I say it's
computation as a base unit of a function
but to try and be a little bit more
intuitive maybe it'd be better to stop
and think about like what do functional
programming languages have in common so
also what do people who do functional
programming what do they seem to want
out of the languages they're using and
then if you're not a functional
programmer why might you want to learn
about it whether you you know go and get
a job as a functional programmer or not
you know you might still want to know
about it for for several reasons and
then lastly you know what kind of
problems are really just does this stuff
really work well for all right so first
what do functional programming languages
have in common so I would say even above
mapping inputs to outputs the idea that
functional programming languages really
have in common is separating the
transforms of data from the data itself
compare that to an object-oriented
approach where you're defining a class
and then that class is gonna have
methods so in fact you define your data
first that's the class and then you
define the methods to operate on the
data in functional programming
you're gonna define a set of functions
that take data and then it's up to those
functions to define whether that data is
acceptable or not either through a type
system or through a set of you know
conditional checking and contracts but
they the reason that you would want to
isolate the transformations of data from
the objects is maybe subtle because
anybody maybe have a thought of why you
might want to split your data from the
objects transforming the data so yeah so
you said you don't know what data you
have and I think that that's a that
that's a really good point and what that
might mean is you do know what data you
have right now but you don't know what
data you're going to have so what what
you can do with a function if you're if
you're dealing with just a
transformation you can extend that
transformation in the face of a lot of
different data without having to modify
all the different definitions of that
data so another reason that you might
want to separate data and transforms is
it makes it easier to write correct
programs so a lot of the rest of this is
going to be about program correctness
and at least when I was in school
learning about programming program
correctness was almost an afterthought I
felt like you know like there was maybe
maybe I'd like one proof class maybe
have like just a little bit of talk
about it and the rest of time is hey go
out and write there if your program does
what it's supposed to do it's correct
right like what else more do you need
and I think that that's I think that
that's a pretty decent way of thinking
about programming until you hit more
complicated systems and more difficult
problems and then suddenly it starts to
fall apart and you really want to know
that your program is going to be robust
to varied inputs and it's going to
behave in an expected manner and I think
that that more than anything is what
functional programming allows you to
have is our programs that behave how you
would expect them to behave
yeah so what do programmers seem to want
so I'm gonna answer that for me at least
the thing I care most about our programs
being correct
obviously I need them to run fast but if
I wanted just speed I'd be writing in C
which I've done and didn't like so here
I am writing programs in languages much
slower than that what you know what are
some other things that you guys think
that you know functional programmers
like what do you care about or what do
you find valuable
yeah so he said transparency in your
code and I think that's a really big big
thing is being able not just to have a
correct program but to make it so that
everybody can tell that it is right like
those two things are very important so
in fact like my next slide is this is
all very going very well everybody's
answers just lead me right into the next
thing so that's awesome yeah so like
obviously functions make it easier to
determine inputs and outputs that's
actually in the definition of a function
right so it should should at least be
able to do that very well and in
addition to that it makes it easy to see
what your code is doing and I have an
example coming up to show that so I say
that functional programs make it easier
to write correct code because it makes
it easier to determine what's coming
into your program what's going out of
your program it's easier to demonstrate
that your program is correct either in
the form of a proof or just casually
just like walking someone through it
because you have inputs and outputs it
becomes much easier yeah Jordan
[Music]
[Music]
oh you know I I so so Jordan Jordan was
saying that the the fact that functional
programs tend to they they tend to
discourage side effects so when you
write a functional program most
functional programmers tend to write
their code so that the inputs and
outputs of their program are the only
things that are going on so because of
that you don't have to worry about some
encapsulated state changing on you that
you didn't know was going to change
possibly by some other part of the
program that's a huge thing and that
that property of things not changing on
you without you expecting it it allows
the composability and allows so many of
the nice properties of functional
programming in fact I have a whole slide
dedicated composition so yeah so you
know I think this really shows like
people who do functional programming
like we're all wanting the same things
like we're all wanting our code to be
easy to read easy to reason about and
then the composition is really important
because it's no good to just have one
small piece of a program easy to read
and easy to reason about in fact I'd
argue you can get that in just about any
dynamic like you can always come up with
a way of writing one piece of a code and
make it so that people can follow it
what becomes difficult is whenever you
have multiple developers or complex
systems and you're trying to compose
those pieces together and still feel
good that each piece independently and
as a whole is correct I mean that's a I
I don't want to act like functional
programming is a silver bullet to that
problem I think that is the problem in
computer software I would say functional
program is a great tool to help with it
but if you have a if you have a better
idea for how to do it I'm I'm all ears
but that I think is a very very powerful
property of functions because you're
mostly dealing with inputs and outputs
where you don't have side effects you
can compose sets of inputs two sets of
outputs to develop more complicated
behaviors
so I'm gonna do a very very simple
example of proving function so raise
your hand if you ever had to do any
proofs in your see either CS courses are
on your own yeah yeah so I see like four
hands up which I mean I never I think I
did in I think I had to do horror logic
proofs in one class and a CS theory
class let me tell you this isn't gonna
be that you're gonna be very happy with
this proof so it's really silly so first
we have we have several suits so we have
clubs spades hearts and diamonds and
then we have a color red in black and
we're gonna write a program that tells
you what color your suit is based on
what suit it is so it's input is going
to be I have this backwards that's so
bad this should say this should say suit
so I can't prove your naming is right it
can only compare structures right which
I actually have a slide about but yeah
so suit and then the case of suit is
going to either be a club a spade a
heart or a diamond right there can be no
other input because we've defined our
input there can be no other output
because we've defined our output so the
proof is unbelievably easel easy right
it's just a proof by termination you
just you just prove termination by
exhaustion you have all your inputs you
just simply work through every single
input and then you have all your outputs
that might seem like a little thing but
I mean the fact that you have completely
bound your input for that problem and
then completely bound your output means
you never have to worry about something
like that being wrong you can imagine
taking this and adding more complexity
maybe it's a club with a number and a
spade with the string but in each case
you can you can work through the same
sort of idea and be very very sure that
that part of your program is correct
there's no way that side effects can
happen there's nothing in here that can
mutate something else and I made it a
ridiculously simple example on purpose
and there are you know plenty of
examples where it does get just too hard
to prove something but the fact that
you can decompose the pieces where you
can prove it
you can decompose the program into
pieces that you can prove and then just
leave as a kernel the part that's really
hard to prove and then write tests
around that piece or monitoring now
around that piece instead of having to
consider all these other pieces and test
through all those other pieces I think
that's a really powerful and worthwhile
technique but yeah so if you're looking
for something more than this for the
proof then there there isn't anything
like I mean I could I could write look
at QED I could write QED at the bottom I
guess and then we'd be improved land for
ship for real that's what I want to say
like when you know when functional
programmers talk about proving things
it's I mean sometimes you know you're
using things like structural induction
and like complicated methods but I mean
that's not that complicated but but a
lot of times it's just this it's the
fact that you can actually read your
inputs and outputs and because you can
read your inputs and outputs you already
know what the function does it's a very
it's a very short argument if you're
talking with another developer and you
read through your inputs and your
outputs and you guys all see what it
does and usually you discover that
somebody typed color instead of suit in
your function yeah so if you're not a
functional programmer why might you care
about these things and this is kind of
what I what I would go back to is like
all programmers when they're writing
code have to decide when their program
is correct the standard that you used to
define that depends on the kind of code
you're writing and you know the
environment that you're writing a lot of
times deadlines and schedules make it
impossible for people to prove every
single part of a program correct so you
have to answer that question in some way
or another and it's good to have a good
definition of that you should also know
what parts of the program what parts of
your system you don't know the answer to
that question like what is correct
behavior what is not correct behavior
this is surprisingly common to
especially in micro service systems
there are lots of micro services that
are defined where parts of the system
are just undefined like you don't you
don't really have a good answer to what
that behavior should be it happens the
behavior happens
you know like why it happens is often
left as an exercise for the user and
then I think another part of this is
okay so you have your you have your
business deadlines you have all of that
stuff but can you confidently say that
over time the code that is in your
system is getting better and not worse
so as you add features and add pieces
are the things that you're writing
making your codebase better do your reef
actors actually reduce bugs you know
things like that I think that the
answers in functional programming are
all very solid for all these things
especially the last one you know at our
company we do a lot of a lot of fast
development very fast development and I
think it's a huge benefit that we can
then go back and iterate that the code
that we've written and make it better
each time and feel more and more
confident in it yeah so I think a lot of
the times the answers to the questions
about how do you prove a program correct
or cultural right so you write tests you
use test different test-driven
development you check for code coverage
and I think that those are great answers
I think everybody should be doing that
you know you definitely should what what
I feel like is that we can have a little
bit more but I do want to talk you know
specifically I want to talk about Ruby
people because you know that's a
community that I've never been involved
with but I listen to a lot of podcasts
and one of the podcasts listen to is a
ruby podcast I'm always impressed with
the way that they they talk about naming
and they pay to pay a lot of attention
to the way you name things and the way
you write your code I think a lot of
that has to do with the fact that it is
completely untyped and so much is
changeable and so much is flexible in
the Ruby language so you have to be very
careful about cultural things like you
know naming conventions and testing
conventions stuff like that but I guess
this is where the reason I wanted to
bring this up was to talk about like why
you might care about functional
programming even if you're not going to
be a functional programmer it's like I
find value in learning about other
programming like
even though I'm you know I probably am
never gonna write any ruby code I never
say never but I've never written any but
it's still very interesting and I
learned a lot learning about that
language yeah so I think that to write
good systems you have to use everything
that you can possibly use so great
culture is important and you know
managing complexity technically also is
important and I think that the technical
management of complexity is where
functional programming really shines so
that's that leads me into the next part
of what I what I want to talk about
which is what I want this to be I would
like to see us take this meetup and turn
it into a meet-up where we're talking
about tools and techniques to write
better code that are not sort of on the
culture side that are more on the
technical side and especially ones
they're outside of the mainstream so you
know I think choosing an alternative
programming language for this is
definitely outside of the mainstream
I think theorem provers would be outside
of the mainstream some languages are
kind of like right on the border like
rust rust is becoming pretty mainstream
so but it's still really interesting and
then FP adjacent subjects just like just
like the core of functional programming
are functions well once you introduce
the idea of a function there are all
these other concepts in mathematics that
are related to functions logic type
theory category theory and then linear
logic sub-discipline of logic but I want
to call out specifically because of
rusts and so I would love for us to
start doing some talks about each of
these categories I know Jordan has done
a few on category theory we've had a few
of those I'd love to see a type theory
talk or if somebody is a rust rust
expert I would love to see a talk about
that I think that would be a really
interesting topic and then other
languages like I said mention Russ a
couple times but Prolog and data log are
two other ways of approaching this
problem
so they have a really a very different
approach from functional programming in
a lot of ways because you talk about
outputs and then you let the computer to
determine the correct way of resolving
those outputs resolving to capture those
outputs but it's a different sort of
transparency but again it's about
writing correct programs you know you
you write a program where if you the
only thing you're specifying is the
output then you know you have the output
so I think that's a really interesting
property as well and then theorem
provers I'll probably have someone do a
talk on TLA plus we've we started using
it at our work and have been very happy
with the results and it's a way of
specifying specifying a program
regardless of whether the programming
language you're writing in has the tools
to do that kind of specification so
that's something I could see be very
very valuable if you're working say it
like a data science shop and you're
writing a lot of Python you don't have
some of the advanced type tools writing
a specification could be really nice of
course we use Haskell and I still find
it incredibly valuable because you can
then actually write a one-to-one mapping
between DL a-plus and Haskell but yeah
and then also I I kind of like to try a
few different kinds of talks you know
this is great but you know if somebody
doesn't feel like they want to come up
here and stand and have everyone stare
at them I can understand why I can be a
little intimidating I know I feel a
little intimidated when I do it I'd be
glad to first of all come up with
someone and just talk to them about
their topic like if you want to do like
an interview style thing or if you don't
want me to talk to you because you don't
like me which I also understand we can
have a bring a buddy so you can have
somebody else talk with you about it or
if you want to do a group talk I'd love
to see that show-and-tell is really nice
too so if you have some super cool
project that you've been working on you
know that you're allowed to show or if
you're not allowed to show and you don't
care and you want to show it anyway I
guess I don't care
but yeah bring it up here and and then
show it off and we'll make sure we ask
questions and you know we won't let you
just swim in and drown so yeah also
solve a problem I I think we're going to
do a couple talks where maybe we propose
a problem and then
different different ways of solving it
in functional programming languages and
other languages I think hopefully you
know I don't intend to pick very
complicated problem so it's going to be
like finding the you know I don't know
the prime you know decomposition of a
number or something like that or you
know reading a string and finding all
the FS in the string you know I don't
because it's hard to do anything more
complicated than that and talk but
that's a great way of like say if we
want to do a language comparison like
maybe comparing a solution in oak camel
to a solution in Python I think that
would be fun
I actually wrote a couple of those that
I'll show after this but yeah and then
I'm also open to any other suggestions
about ways to do stuff but I I think
that it's really neat that we have
something like this and I'd like to see
it grow and become more more interesting
so there's a few more things after the
thank you I got my slides out of order
there we go
so I'll come back to the pinky so yeah
Jordan right before this started he
reminded me that maybe be useful to put
some links to things and I'll slack them
in the in the channel but one really
good resource for learning about
goings-on in functional programming
communities there's a Haskell newsletter
and I subscribe to that's main way I
learn about stuff that like summarizes
what's going on in high school and a lot
of times I'll talk about other
programming languages too and then if
you're looking for something fun to do
and you're looking for a functional
programming product project there's this
ICF pecan contest so that's I don't know
I see whatever that stands for and then
functional programming so so we do this
contest of my work every year for I
think four years now and oh yeah see I
didn't wanna say that's like maybe it's
French
and so I'm not gonna just say that
International Conference it's what
Jordan says it was I could have take I
could have guessed that and then but the
concepts are really interesting so one
year there was a you had to they gave
you this they gave you these files for
3d printers like a magical 3d printer
they made and you had
to verify that you could build the build
the object that they said that you could
build I mean obviously it's all just
virtual but it was really neat another
one was there was like you had to find
the shortest path for a gondola going
through Venice and that was really
interesting because you learned a lot
about shortest path algorithms and how
like you know that's a really hard
algorithm I mean you probably already
know that but you really feel it when
you try and build something has to run
in under a minute
so and it's got 40,000 nodes to compute
and it fails so one was we folded
origami so like you had to you had to
fold all these different shapes they
gave you like a map and you had to try
and fold that shape we managed to fold a
piece of paper in half I called it half
egami and that's as far as we got but I
was pretty proud of that yeah so it'd be
really neat maybe we can maybe we can
try and do one of that if anyone's
interested we could try and do some of
that as a group and like not just be
like like all isolated alright ready
thank you I got it in the right order
now does anybody have any questions for
me
you might starting out with Mike oh okay
so yes so in your work home workshop do
you use utilize all the functional
programming concepts you know reduction
sure yeah so company I work for is plow
and we we use Haskell for something like
90% of our back-end code and then we use
reason now for something like 90% of our
front-end code so we have functional
programming all the way up and down the
stack we use a little bit of C for some
stuff and we use Nix now for doing for
doing builds and deployment so that's a
functional programming environment for
sort of building configurations to
deploy software
we're very we're all in on the
functional thing you know for better for
worse we're all in so was that was your
first exposure to functional programming
then through your current position or
was this something that you sought out
because cloud was known for facing those
concepts yeah so so I'm one of the
founders of plow and so we we selected
it because I liked it that they were
using they were using PHP and C sharp
and my sequel and they're running the my
sequel on a Windows Server and it was
look I mean the programmer who did it
before me I like him a lot he's a good
guy I was just I didn't know those
languages I knew let's see I knew
Haskell and Lisp scheme and C and the
idea of developing a web site in C
sounded like the worst thing in the
world so I I decided I was going to
rewrite it all in high school and I did
that but I'm happy happy with that
decision now seven years ago so
it's been a while no further questions
for me anybody else all right
well thanks guys you know it also I
guess I the other thing is that if
anybody has talks feel free to message
me on slacker just message in the
channel but I would really I'd really
love a rest talk
if anyone's doing any reason at love a
reason talk or Haskell talk really just
anything
we had a Erlang talk a long time ago I
feel like maybe it's another time for
another airline you talk so alright guys
that's all I have thank you so much